Herkese merhaba en son bir okul müdürünü
ne zaman
dinlediniz çok eğitimci var Belki daha
önce dinlememişsin ama
velilerden bugün dinleyen mi
var cumaları genelde İstiklal Marşı'ndan
önce müdürler alırdı telefonu şey
mikrofonu eline ve yarım saat Nutuk
çekerlerdi Aslında çok takıntılıdır okul
müdürleri ben deok şu koltuklar boş
arkadaşlar arkadan öne doğru bir
gelelim Niye boş diyeceksiniz Çünkü
Bankacılar gitti para gidince genel
müdür gidince oralar boş kaldı bir
eğitimciye dinlemek Bankacılar için
Tabii Belki çok hoş değildi o yüzden
koltuklar boş bir öğretmen olmak müdür
olmak ne demek Türkiye'de ne şartlarda
öğretmen olunuyor biraz size ondan
bahsedeceğim Ankaralı arkadaşlar var
İnşallah anımız hiçbir anımız Kara
olmaz küçük bir dokunuş insanlara
çocuklara kendi kapasitem de neler
yaptım Kara Sevdamız çocuklar için
nelerle mücadele ettim ve her şeye
rağmen 18
yılda neler yaptımı kısaca size
özetlemeye
çalışacağım
çocuklar hep meraklıdır ve hep bir
yerler seyretmeye çalışırlar Ve durmadan
soru
sorarlar Peki bu Baba ne yapıyor
Sizce annelik çok zor biri bana sorsa ki
ne istersin bu
dünyada anne olmak isterim derim
gerçekten bir babayım Ama anne olmak çok
farklı bir şey bizi kurtaracak olan
belki
ülkemizi bu muasır devletler seviyesine
getirecek olan gerçekten anneler
eğitilmiş kadınlar lazım bize Çünkü
çocuklarımızı iyi eğmem gerekiyor o
yüzden sizi tekrar Alak istiyorum
dinleyemedim sonra videodan dinleyeceğim
inşallah ben 1998 yılında öğretmenliğe
başlarken profesyonel liglerde futbol
oynuyordum çok da
popülerdir yani iyiydim sonra atamam
yapıldı Yozgat'ın çekek ilçesinin 4
dilim
köyüne babam devlet memuru dört kardeş
okuyoruz tek maaşla Hadi dedi Sen bir
memur ol yük omzumdan atayım yok dedim
Ben futbolcu olacağım Baba transfer
olacağım Hakikaten de vardı transfer yok
dedi sen git bir şey ol Bir gün o günkü
karamanspor oynuyorum Karamanlı bir
bakan var Onun yanına gittik kulüp
başkanıyla Tamam dedi İşini hallederiz
Karaman'a aldırırız seni al Olmadı bir
tercih yapmak zorunda kaldım metrodan
indik üniversitede O zaman yarın
doçentli şimdi profesör oldu Gazi
Üniversitesinde Hakkı hocamla
karşılaştık Babam ve ben tesadüf Hakkı
Hocam dedi ki Mete dedi havadaki iki
kuştan cepteki bir kuş
iyidir sen git öğretmen ol ve onun
demesiyle gidip öğretmen oldum ben o
lafın üzerine ve şimdi Buradayım hayatım
boyunca Öğretmen olmak istemedim hiç
aklımda yok hep bize sorarlardı ne olmak
istiyorsun hiçbir zaman öğretmen
Demedim öyle başladım köye gittim 5
sınıf bir arada 54 öğrenci okuma yazma
nasıl öğretilir hiç bilmiyorum tek
başıma köyde dağın başında böyle çok da
güzel bir manzarası vardı türkü tutturur
durmadan ders anlatırdım
çocuklara bulaşık yıkamayı Bilmem yemek
yapmayı bilmem çamaşır yıkamayı hiç
bilmem ilk gittiğimde ilk aldığım şey
çift çanak anten ve televiz Çünkü
şampiyonlar lig kanal o diğer antenden
gösterirdi onu seyretmek zorundaydım
Çünkü arkadaşlarım
oynuyordu Evet hayatta tercihler zaten
bizi bu hale getiriyor her tercih bir
vazgeçiş Aslında ve ben öğretmen olmayı
tercih ettim sonra Bitlis'in Mut
ilçesinin çiğdemalan köyüne
gittim Bir Kar yağıyor Dün konuştum 3
metre kar var yine tandır dağının arka
tar
mutkiye bağlı bir köy ama m'den yol yok
Bitlis'ten de yol yok Biz Siirt'ten
dolanıyor köye gitmek için o tarafı
bilen var mı bilmiyorum Veysel karın
Türbesi vardır ziyaret diye oradan 30
kilometredir köy 30 kilometreyi 3,5
saatte gidiyordu araba Normal yaz
günü köye ilk gittiğim gün tabii hemen
geri dönmek istedim ama araba yoktu
Sonra bir ay sonra
dönebildim Bir ay boyunca Yollar
kapalıydı çünkü
Çünkü hayatımız böyle geçiyordu
çocuklarla
beraber sonra tabii Bahar
Geldi Bahar gelince biliyorsunuz pireler
artar köyde Fatih vardı ev arkadaşım
yani oda arkadaşım her şeyim İstanbullu
o da bilmez Bir de ben de hiç bilmem ilk
defa pireyle orada karşılaştık her akşam
pire yakalıyoruz ve bir bardak suyun
içine Onu atıyoruz Çünkü böyle onu
öldürmeniz gerekiyor ama beceremiyoruz
bardağın içine atınca boğulmuş pireler
orada
öğrendik Fatih dedim pireyi bir pire
geliyor işte Tabii orada da yine çift
çanak var Bu arada söyleyeyim
mutlaka maç seyrediyoruz
eee bir gün bir şey ısırdı dedim
herhalde bir Kire dedim Fatih Işığı aç
hemen eş of manı sırdım baktım falan yok
çiyan mış çiyan ısırmış beni Tabii bir
şey olmadı gidemiyorsunuz ki hemen köye
şey e ambulans ya da işte öyle bir şey
yok Ancak helikopter
gelebilir Sonra bir gün şeyde maç
seyrediyoruz Milan Beşiktaş oynuyor
İtalya'da benim arkadaşım Ümit aynı
odada kalırdık genç takımda oynarken bir
baktım Orada
oynuyor Beşiktaş'ta oynuyor ve milanla
karşılaşıyor stara maç şovu açtım BBG
var o zaman Biri Bizi Gözetliyor orada
da Volkan var 04 Volkan ismi O da bizim
diğer arkadaş Defansa oynardık üçümüz O
da Show TV'de Ben de köyde pire ay pire
topluyorum Neyse bir gün o zaman
Siirt'in Siirt retba vardı Beşiktaş
geldi de ümitle bu fotoğrafı çektirmiş
tik Hayat böyle başladı Benim hayatım
çok zor günler Bence ben yaşadığım için
sonra bir gün okul müdürü olmaya karar
verdim çünkü ihtiyaç vardı bir okulda
akyurt'un kozaya Köyü İlkokulu
ama sizin ve bizim hep aklımızdaki okul
müdürü Hamil beydi o zamanlar Hayat
Bilgisi
dizisindeki Aslında çok bir şey yapmadım
Sadece bir okul müdürlüğü yapmaya
çalışıyorum götüreceğiz sizleri bu okulu
diğer okullardan ayıran özellik ise
öğrencilere sunduğu olanaklar başkente
yaklaşık 70 K uzaklıktaki Bu okul bir
köy okulu olmasına rağmen bir İlköğretim
Okulundan daha donanımlı öğretmenlerin
özverili çabaları ve hayırseverlerin
yardımlarıyla donatılan okulun
öğrencileri kar tatili hiç gelmesin
istiyor okulumuzda basketbol sahası var
on da oynamayı çok seviyorum
vı var Onu da seviyorum En sevdiğim
dersler başta bilgisayar olarak hepsi
Karacakaya köyden
geliyorum ulumi
öğ Ankara'nın Akyurt ilçesine bağlı
kozayağı İlköğretim Okulunun 150
öğrencisi var taşımalı eğitimin
yapıldığı okulun 109 öğrencisi çevredeki
üç köyden
[Müzik]
geliyor 5 yıl önce kurulan okulun hemen
hemen bütün ihtiyaçları başta okul
müdürü olmak üzere öğretmenlerin
özverili çabaları ve hayırseverlerden
sağlanan katkılarla karşılanıyor ku
azaldığı yerlerde bizim uyguladığımız
kuvvetle beraber derslik sisteminin
uygulandığı okulda öğrenciler her dersi
o ders için özel oluşturulmuş sınıflar
da alıyorlar okulun 10 öğrencilik bir
ana sınıfı da
var Kaç tane
not hangi deresin Şimdi siz matematik
seviyor musun matemati Evet
hiçb açmayacak çiçek kalmayacak yani
olsa bütün çiçekler açacak amacımız bu
Bu okulda herkes mutlu
[Müzik]
olacak 2005 yılında derslik sistemini
Biz uygulamaya başlamıştık ve onu çekmek
için gelmişti TRT Sonra dedi ki biz
bütün Okulu çekelim bir 18 dakikalık bir
program
yaptılar okul müdürlüğü zordu
orada ama Köyü ve köyden çocuklar
geliyordu Ere ulaşmak çok zordu Ben de
anneler toplantısı yapardım O sebepten
yine bütün kadınları eğitmek için Çünkü
kızlarını liseye göndermiyor lardı en
yakın lise 17 kilometreyi ve araba
yoktu Servis şoföründen taşımalı eğitim
olduğu için arabayı alırdım minibüsü o
üç keyi Gezer İmamla beraber anons eder
camide kadınları camiye camiden
Okulun olduğu köye getirirdim DT köyün
kadını toplardım
ve Herkes gelirken de yanında pasta
börek bir şey getirsin
derdim Mutlaka gelen toplantıya bir
şeyler getirirdik gün gibi olurdu ve ben
de ilçeden ya da
şehirden kadınlarla konuşacak bir bayan
bir kadın bir avukat bir doktor mutlaka
bir lise olurdu ve
öyleli liseye göndermelerini ikna ettim
yaz tatilinde 2 ay o zaman SBS vardı SBS
kursu açmıştık Biz öğretmenler kurs
veriyorduk çocuklar
ve o çocuklar Şu anda birisi odde biri
tıpta okuyor bu kızlar öğretmen
oldular kadınlar ikna etmek zor oldu ama
tabii sonra bundan sonra iki tane okul
kurdum biri gölbaşı'da biri akuta
değişik yerlerde ve bu efsanevi dediler
ama tabii biz onu kabul etmiyor ben escu
hocamla da görüştüm onlar çok fazla
olmuş benim
için Ankara'nın merkezinde Altındağ'da
Çinçin denen Polis Amca çinçin'de Polis
Amca İlköğretim okuluna müdürü oldu
Oraya kimse okul müdürü olmak
istemiyordu hala yok kimse olmak
istemiyor Çünkü Google bile girememiş
oraya bir fotoğraf çekmek için polis
amca Ortaokuluna bir sene boyunca
öğretmenler polis arabasıyla ekip
arabasıyla gelmişler o
zamanlar Bu da benim odadan
dışarı baktığım
pencereydi aslında bütün okul müdürleri
dışarıyı bu şek görüyorlar bir
parmaklığın arkasında hepsi odasına
kitlenmiş çevrede ne olup bitiyor
ilgilenmeden odanın içinde oturup
dışarıda neler oluyor Bir bakalım
demiyorlar maalesef
oradaki öğrenciler böyleydi Yılmaz
öğrenciler vardı Bir gün 1 sınıf E
öğrencisi sınıfa bir girdim orada
oturuyor Petek var petkin üstünde
oturmuş dersi oradan dinliyor öğretmen
de ders anlatıyor girdim Merhaba
nasılsınız falan konuştuk hiç çocuk
istifini bozmuyor Hani bir görüntü var
bende bir de müdürüm ya Nasıl Korkmaz
benden diye şöyle bir gittim
yok çocuğun ununda değil müdür girmiş
öğretmen girmiş iri yarıy mış Çünkü
hakikaten Yılmaz çocuklar Çünkü oradaki
çocuklar çok farklı şeyler yaşıyorlar
öğretmenle konuştum sonra ailesindeki
problemleri anlatınca Tabii hak
veriyorsunuz ve ondan sonra o çocuğa
farklı gözle bakmaya
başlıyorsunuz Önemli olan da buydu Yaşar
Kemal'in dediği gibi o gövde değil
aslında önemli olan önemli olan yüreği
Bu çocukların onlar da mangal gibi yürek
var Çünkü her şeyi yaşıyorlar her
kötülüğü belli bir yaşa
[Alkış]
geliyorlar ama her çocuk okula giderken
aklında tek bir şey vardır hiçbirisi
matematik öğreneceğim bugün Fen
bilgisinde şu deneyi yapacağım falan
diye gitmez oyun oynamaya gider bugün bu
arkadaşımla bunu oynayacağım Dün bunu
oynamıştık Buna devam edeceğim bugün maç
yapacağız gol atacağım diye gider
hepsinin aklında oyun vardır Siz oyun
oynamaya devam ederseniz Okulu
sevdirirsiniz o çocuklar devamlı Okula
gelmek isterler Biz de okulda işte
robotik burada da var first
legol yaptık
gazetelere çıktık kütüphaneler
kurduk en son ben ayrılırken 11 branşta
36 takımımız
vardı 36 takım kız erkek karışık kız
futbol takımımız da
vardı sonra biz festivaller yapıyorduk
spor festivalleri çevredeki okulları
toplayıp bunu yapmak için ilk önce
öğretmenlere oynatmak gerekiyor oyunları
hep beraber oynuyorduk önce çocuklarla
oynamadan önce öğretmenler öğretip sonra
çocuklarla beraber oynuyorduk bu şekilde
toplam kalite yönetim
dalında dereceler aldı
okul sonra bir projeye dahil olmuştuk
uluslararası ilham Projesi ve o
projedeki başarımız dolayı İngiltere
spor bakanı okulumuzu ziyaret
etti kısa bir videosu var onun
da
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Ç
spor bak Oyun oyn bahçe çlar
berer tane penalt ATT
[Müzik]
dışar
Burada bulunmaktan ne kadar Onur
duyduğumu söyleyerek başlamak
[Müzik]
istiyorum ve okulumuzu da yaptıkları her
şeyden öt bir tebrik etmek
istiyorum gördüğüm her şey bana
anlatıyor ki bu okul yaptığı
faaliyetlerle öğrencilerini
çalışanlarını ilham veriyor ve
amaçlarını
gerçekleştiriyor Biz ilham vermeye ilham
verenler kulübüyle ekibiyle beraber o
zamanlar
başlamıştık ve hala devam etmeye
çalışıyoruz bunu İngiltere'den fark
ettiler de
Türkiye'den maalesef
ilham verenler ekibimiz Bunlar hiçbir
şey tek başına yapamaz okul müdürü
Değerdir ama ekibini
kurabilir Süper Lig hakemi Ali paly
birisi birisi A Milli Takım buok takım
kaptanı diğeri Güreş dünya üncüsü diğeri
de bir futbol hakemi
arkadaş bizim Keşke spor bakanımız da
orada olsaydı projeyi Biz de ona
anlatabilseydim
en son son bu Eylül ayında yine Çin Çin
kültür sanat festivali
düzenledik çocuklar hep Böylelikle
kendilerini bulmaya çalışıyorlar
sosyalleşmek Çok
önemli çocuklar Çünkü
sosyalleşmede ve insan haklarıyla ilgili
bir proje yaptık Çünkü çocukların
birbirine saygısı yoktu birbirlerine
şiddet gösteriyorlardı
her teneffüs benim kapımın
önünde sıra
olurdu kavga etmiş çocuklar bu insan
hakları ve demokrasi ile ilgili
yaptığımız projeyle bunda azalma
görüldü ama bunu tabii okul içinde de
yaşatmanın gerekiyor öğretmenlere bunu
anlatmak gerekiyor velilere anlatmanız
gerekiyor aktif vatandaşlık diye
bir projemiz vardı orada da yine hoşgörü
Barış eşitlikle ilgili şeyler anlattık
hep oyunlar oynadık çocuklarla beraber
hiç ayırt etmeden Hiç kimliklerini buras
yargılamadan bir Kamu Spotu çekildi
sonra bu Kamu Spotu
yayınlanmadı yukarıdan işaret ediyorlar
bittir diye O yüzden hızlı
geçiyorum ha ben bunları her yerde
anlatıyorum çok
rahat
Çünkü kimseden korkum yok Sonra başka
bir okula gittim bu Okuldan ayrılmak
zorunda kaldım polis amcadan dediler ki
niye ayrıldın Tam 5 bu5 yıl
kalmıştım kendimce de bir sürü iş yaptım
Sonra bizi değerlendirmeye tuttular okul
müdürü olarak 100 üzerinden Ben 94 aldım
dedim ki ben demek ki işimi düzgün
yapmıyorum ben 94 aldım Artık buradan
ayrılmam gerekiyor ve Ankara'da
Çankaya'da bir bahçelievlerde başka bir
okula gittim oraya da gittiğimde
çocuklarla yine iyi ilişkiler kurmaya
çalıştım Bu satrancın benim için çok
önemi var masamın Önünde mutlaka bir
satranç masası vardır Polis amca da bir
gün otururken biri nar atarak geldi
Eee bağırıyor koridorlarda okul müdürü
nerede falan diye Genç bir çocuk girdi
odama konuştuk Sohbet ettik tanıştık
Benden önceki okul müdürünü bıçaklamaya
çalışmış sonra okuldan kaçmış 3ün kattan
atlamış çocuk satrancı görünce benimle
satranç oynamaya başladı Ben bund da çok
iyiyimdir Hocam dedi iddialı oynayalım
dedi kazanan şey kaybeden pavyona
götürür
dedi Tamam dedim Çünkü bir öncekinden
Bir önceki okul müdüründen dolayı buna
hayır deme imkanı
yok yani Adam baştan söyledi Ben bunu
yaptım dedi ve Hakikaten iyi oynuyordu
çocuk Beni
yendi Yani orayı Evet karıştırmayalım
pavyon
kısmını Burada da yine Bu okulda da
sıkıntılar var Çankaya'da Ankara'nın en
iyi okullarından Birisi bir gün Milli
Eğitim müdürümüz bize dedi ki siz dedi
bu Türkiye'nin en iyi okulların müdürler
isiniz ama öyle değilmiş gittim çatıya
çıktım çatı akıyor Tuvaletler
akıtıyor ve yine İnşaat başladı yine
sıkıntılarımız başladı her tarafı
düzeltme aşaması çocuklarla yine sporlar
şeyler oyunlar yine insan haklarıyla
ilgili şeyler
yaptık bu çocuğun yazdığı çok hoşuma
gitti 2 dakika istiyorum
Üstat ülkemde Barış olmasını istiyorum
Hiç kimsenin üzülmesini kavga etmesini
istemiyorum bütün çocuklar mutlu olsun
istiyorum çocuklar Üzülüp ağlamasınlar
Ben bunu
diliyorum Çocukların istekleri
buydu orada da tabii ekibimiz
vardı öğretmenler çok önemli ve bu
yaşında 103 yaşında öğretmenimizi okula
getirmiştik bu öğretmenler gününde
Atatürk'le geçirdiği sohbeti bize
anlattı hepimizin hayatında kırılma
noktaları var Benimki
de o polis amcada yaşadığım olaylardır
ve bu bazı sözler hayatımda hep
bana yol vermiştir yol göstermiştir Dün
bir arkadaşımız sordu sen nasıl bu hale
geldin diye
bazı sözler beni bu hale getirdi bazı
şarkılarda hep en iyisini yapmaya
çalıştım ve hiç kimseye iltifat etmedim
hiç kimseyi
aldatmadım memleket için hakiki Mefkure
neyse onu yapmaya
çalıştım Herkes de benim önüme bir sürü
manialar engeller yığdı hiçbirisi
le muhatap olmadım ve hepsini geçmeye
çalıştım bazen alttan bazen üstten
Kendimi hiç büyük görmedim hep zayıf
küçük bir hiç olarak gördüm ve hiçbir
zaman da bu panoda asılı bir resim
olmadım ve hep bulunduğum okullarda bir
Host daha bırakmaya çalıştım Hasan Ali
Yücel'in çok güzel bir sözü var bu
yüzden buradayım ne için yaşadığımızı
bilmek fikirlerin en gücü başı ve sonu
işte Ülkü budur Gerçek sevgi budur iyi
yaşayarak yaşamamızın amacını iyi
bilerek ve ona yaklaşmanın saadetini
duyarak kaderimizin bizi getireceği ana
yani güler yüzlü Gözümüz arkada
kalmaksızın
varmak hayatı vazifen Bittiği anda
bitirmek ne aldanmak Ne aldatmak ne
avunmak Ne avutmak gözü pek yüreği
yumuşak olmak doğruyu kuşun ötmesi gibi
sıkıntısız
söyleyebilmek bazı şeyler ayağınızda
diken olm
olmuyor bizim öğretmenlerimizin çoğunun
Ayağında çok dikan var emin olun çoğunun
okul müdürünün de var Herkes bir şeyler
yapmak istiyor Herkes çok
çalışıyor ama bizim için önemli olan
aslında bu Çanakkale ruhu Hepimiz
beraber
çalışamıyoruz hepimizi ayrıştırmaya
çalışıyorlar hepimizi farklı yönlerimize
bizi dışlamaya ötekileştirmeye
çalışıyorlar insan olarak kimseyi kabul
etmezsek sadece Yaratandan Ötürü ondan
sonra bazı şeylere mahkum kalırız
köprüden önceki son çıkışı kaçırmayalım
önümüzde zor günler bizi
bekliyor Şimdi bir okula geçtim İzmir'de
başka bir okul O da inşaat halinde
maalesef
eğitimle feda edecek tek bir fert bile
yok bu insanlardan birisi bizim
yetiştirdiğimiz çocuklardan birisi
olabilir ya bundan önce 20 Eylül'de bu
okula gelmiştim başka bir program için o
zaman da Ankara'daki diğer patlamanın
olduğu
gündü yine biz kan ağladık burada ve
yine patlamadan sonra ik gün sonra
buraya geldim ya Aziz Sancar
yetiştirebilirsiniz bir öğretmen olarak
ya da o patlamada kendini imha eden bir
adam O tek kişi çok önemli Burada bir
sürü öğretmen arkadaş var Lütfen
yaptığınız işi hafife almayın çok önemli
bir iş yapıyoruz Herkes bizim
itibarımızı düşürmeye çalışsa da buna
bakanlar dahil az çalışıyoruz gibi görse
de öyle değil biz çok önemli bir insanız
ve İnsanların hayatına gerçekten Küçük
dokunuşlar Büyük Hayaller bırakabiliyor
lütfen kararmasın Ankara teşekkür
ederim